last time on Dragon Ball Z half a person
had know the epic conclusion about damn
time you maroon 5 to put the soda pop in
that I get to use a fork
jeez I'm down there that first is pissed
calm down there I hope there's liquid in
there because I formed like two drops
when I win amazing things happen this is
incredible
this is totally gonna mess up the
obvious I don't care man that's cool
it's speaking to us in Morse code what
does your kid
[Laughter]
I love drives why don't I get more dry
is so cool we've two more oh yeah
we have extra dry ice but it's not this
big nice solid block I think that's the
already looking popsicle ooh I forgot
this wasn't clean all right it's gonna
have some flavors to it tastes fruity
oh god that bag looks horrible we're not
gonna show you the bag we've been
talking about the bag the whole time
we're not gonna show you the bag until
the end of the challenge and it's bad
it's real bad you're gonna trick me and
I was gonna do rock again now you're
gonna be
[Music]
[Applause]
it might be good honey honey mustard you
know I like honey mustard yogurt
dressing I don't know I've had yogurt
dressing before but not this smell very
good
smells like honey mustard but it smells
also wrong I had to excavate mine out
the fork was actually getting embedded
in here and the fork is like frozen
solid so my breathing kind of I got a
Boober um Buffy do this with you at a
Hoover on yours it might be bad not
delicious if you vomit in the bag we
emptied the vomit too we have to make a
pumpkin Buffy cool that's pretty good
you look promise okay rod you want tasty
replacement
I'll try I didn't go to the bathroom I
just went off camera drink some water
that is horrifyingly bad that's a riff
eclis bad horse one that's by far and we
got one more that might be worse kale
parmesan oh it is good though I love
that you've got a 50/50 shot of getting
something really delicious
congratulations you're gonna trick me
this next time
oh we're gonna treat you you're not
gonna do I'm gonna do rock I swear on my
mother I'm gonna do rock so again to
save time because we're both running out
of camera battery and camera space and
also the driest is raining we got just a
little bit this channel level I'm gonna
get this one started
I'm gonna make a small popsicle of the
kale parmesan it's number two it's
number two on the roster and if one of
these girls will keep it number two so
it doesn't change all right so this is
gonna be just be ready because it's got
oil in it and I don't know if it's gonna
freeze so we just need to see if you
will
[Music]
all right so that one's gonna be there
this is a beautiful bathtub beautiful
popsicle oh I'm sorry
I go Scottish when I'm nervous
definitely tastes like Coke you know
like frozen coke from Burger King
yeah like okay see ya oh wow that is
just like cool so you're not sick this
is ready to go so if anyone gets this
it's immediate what a three better than
whoo it's better than two [ __ ] Oh God
why are you you put it we missed it
I did not all right this is ready we're
trying we're trying to do math and we're
not good at that so it wasn't working
out too well so I don't imagine this is
gonna be pretty bad yeah the fact that
it's frozen make to solve again it
tastes like a carrot literally for you
biting into a carrot who's literally
does a carrot that's been firmed back
into a carrot
good it's a carrot yeah through our
mathematical process that up there's no
way that Tyler can win and buy points
because there were only 13 challenges
and the last bag is the 14 so it'd be
unfair to say that the loser has to eat
it because he'd already have to eat it
I've already gotten more than him so
we'll do a final test and see do a best
two out of three
[Music]
[Applause]
my secret has been for two choices so
this is really frozen we know what it's
gonna be
God why did I ever feel my stress this
cannot be good
[Music]
oh no I got a permit
oh my god that was so bad
ordinarily I'd be like trying don't try
this little beaut and it even got some
carrot splashes on there from the last
one but that didn't cut the flavor at
all oh my god that's terrible
okay so we got to fight for the right to
the that was way worse than that anymore
and it's hard to say way worse it was
way worse like way worse sweet tastes
delicious
is there a way to purposely lose no oh
you get it oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that's okay
what a lovely lovely thing no different
slat mountain dudes are saying all the
carbonation gets blown away of the cold
I like that okay so now comes a big bag
reveal uh we've been we've been waiting
this up can we not empower their chanson
because he have the cream with the oils
and that doesn't how are there chunks
I can't even stomach oh my god demon
portal I can't even look at it oh my god
why is it so chunky stop talking about
it it's so chunky dude where you got a
dress
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm gonna try not to I mean it can't be
that bad you will see another video just
flip it over okay just get a nice
coating on the other side
hey doesn't look so bad anymore I like
the dick on it we're men of our word
[Laughter]
just a little bit doesn't have to be a
big one it's mostly sriracha but there
was the lemon-lime in that bite oh you
took a bigger bite this day
[Music]
okay we did it in my mouth eat the whole
popsicles my goodness okay so anyway I'm
trying to talk here alright so that is
the dry ice popsicle challenge it was a
lot of fun took a while but I mean those
those like the most fun up shouts
shooting a video in a long time
legitimately that was really fun so we
hope you enjoyed it next out any final
words from you no I other than if you
guys decide to make popsicles with dry
ice at home we'd certainly like to see
it and yeah tell us in the comments of
below what your favorite parts work yeah
and you know choose tasty ingredients
for your popsicles because my god this
this bag of at the real horrors that you
can still see the box more chunks is it
sleep dude it's true I forgot
oh we're gonna read in there oh it's not
so good so anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see
more challenged lives like this let us
know in the comments below thanks again
and as always we'll see you in the next
video bye